WENDY LI: I have an interesting
relationship with photography.
I came to this point
last year where
I didn't know if I wanted to
even make photographs anymore.
And I didn't know what I
wanted to take photographs of.
I went back to sort
of asking myself--
why do I love photography?
And what about photography
makes it so interesting
and makes it worth my time?
My name is Wendy Li.
I'm in the class of 2015.
And I'm concentrating in
the Woodrow Wilson School
with a certificate
in visual arts.
So while I'm writing a thesis
for the Woodrow Wilson School
on the role of women in
developing economies,
specifically in rural
China, this thesis
is specifically to fulfil the
requirement for my visual arts
certificate.
My senior thesis is
about the process
of discovering your identity
and of creating memories
through photographs.
I went back to the
first photographs
I was ever exposed to, which
were my family photographs.
And I realized that
my love of photography
really came from these
photographs and everything
that they contained.
What you see behind me is
actually the manifestation
of the process of
discovering who I am
and who my family is, especially
because we're immigrants
and because most of my
family I've never met before.
These photographs
were really a way
to process that information.
JOE SCANLAN: As an
advisor, where I gave her
maybe the most helpful advice
was helping her figure out
what kind of structure
the show should have.
There were so many threads
that went through the show.
You could pick up
any one of them
and have a really meaningful
experience in the exhibition
and maybe not ever really have
the same experience that Wendy
has with the material.
But it wouldn't mean that
your experience was any less
valuable.
WENDY LI: In some
ways I kind of see
my work in the
Woodrow Wilson School
as being completely
opposite from my work
in the visual arts.
And I think the
two work very well
and are sort of symmetrical.
This project I think really
sort of distills a lot
of what we think of as
abstract political ideas.
We think of economic
reform as a very abstract
political economic idea.
We think of migration
also as a very sort
of abstract
international concept.
What a lot of people
don't realize, I think,
especially, is that these are
very real human things that
are happening and they're
real human experiences.
And so even though I spent so
much time in the Wilson School
going through data sets, combing
through international relations
theory and political
philosophy, a lot of it
still doesn't really matter
until you tie it back
to real people.
Most people would be
able to see these photos
and instantly recognize that
they're personal photos.
A lot of people will
look at these photographs
and think, oh, these
are photos that
could be in history textbooks.
They're very removed,
especially for,
I think, the average American
student at Princeton.
They would look at
these and not be
able to relate to them
personally at all.
But I think when people start
moving through the timeline,
and they realize that
the same people are
in all of these photographs,
and as the photographs become
more approachable
and more familiar,
that they'll realize that these
seemingly alien concepts are
actually real experiences
that you can relate to.